In addition to the questions on templates, we also got a lot of questions
about separating your data and your Python information
and your app handlers into multiple files.
Right now, we're basically doing everything in main.py,
which is okay because our web applications are small enough that it doesn't really matter.
But if you're going to be writing something for production
for everyone potentially to be using, then that doesn't really work anymore.
Once you start getting into thousands or tens of thousands
or even more lines of code, it's just unfeasible.
So there are a lot of ways you can do that depending on what language you're using
and what template engines you're using.
The template editors we're going to be talking about in another video.
With Python it's actually pretty simple.
Any Python files in the same folder you just say,
"import [the name of the file]" except for the file extension, .py,
and that's really about it.
It's very simple to use.
I will be linking to the docs on that, too, but that's essentially all you have to do for it.
And I would recommend if you're doing production web application design
or any kind of serious web application design, that you want to start separating that
into logical chunks so that it is easier for you to maintain,
and other people to maintain, too, if you're working with other people.